This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档 I-Heart 播客节目。“纯正人类”。2%。这是在有扶梯可选时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中展现出的坚韧意志、体能以及抗压能力的种种表现。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一番艰难困苦，你终将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO PERCENT，可在 IHeart Radio 苹果播客或各大播客平台收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。对84年我也记忆犹新。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚克斯·英格利什。每集我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的一年。那真是个疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯带来的《知难而进》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得把它用出来。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcast 或你听播客的任何地方收听并订阅《知难而进》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe,
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。相信闺蜜，
on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back. Welcome back to another episode of the psychology of your 20s, new listeners, old listeners. It's so great to have you here. So great to have you here for this super exciting topic that I am so pumped to talk about today.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回来。欢迎收听《20多岁的心理学》的又一期节目，新听友，老听友。很高兴你们来到这里。很高兴你们来到这里，收听我今天极其兴奋要聊的这个超级激动人心的话题。
And that is the psychology of New Year's resolutions. There was no better time. to talk about this, then now. 2023 is right around the corner. Maybe you're listening to this in the month of January. The new year has just started. And with that, many of us tend to make some pretty big promises or goals for ourselves for the new year for 2023, which I think is honestly incredible, a great idea. I think that New Year's resolutions are a really kind of positive thing to reflect on and to set for ourselves as we enter into a new chapter.
那就是新年决心的心理学。没有比现在更好的时机来谈论这个了。2023年就在眼前。也许你正在一月份收听这期节目。新的一年刚刚开始。伴随着新年，我们中的许多人往往会为自己新的一年、为2023年许下一些相当重大的承诺或目标，老实说，我认为这棒极了，是个绝妙的主意。我认为新年决心是一件非常积极的事情，在我们迈入新篇章之际，值得我们去反思并为自己设定目标。
You know, they're all about self-improvement and agency and growth, which I think also really embodies this show. So I'm a big fan and if you are setting New Year's resolutions this year, I want you to succeed. So today we are going to break down the history and also the same. psychology behind New Year's resolutions, why it is that we set them to begin with, why they often fail, but also what we can learn from our failures and the failure of New Year's resolutions so that we can succeed so that we can see our New Year's resolutions through. Essentially, what I really want to understand and explain in today's episode is what it is that determines the success of a New Year's resolution. There is so much fascinating research behind
你知道，它们全关于自我提升、自主性和成长，我认为这也真正体现了本节目的精神。所以我非常支持这一点，如果你今年也下了新年决心，我希望你能成功。所以今天我们将剖析新年决心的历史以及背后的心理学，我们为什么最初会许下这些决心，为什么它们经常失败，但同时我们也能从失败和新年决心的破灭中学到什么，以便我们能够成功，能够将新年决心的目标进行到底。从本质上讲，我在今天的节目中真正想要理解和解释的是，究竟是什么决定了新年决心的成败。这背后有如此迷人的研究，
this, so many interesting concepts like Roman philosophy, self-efficacy and self-improvement theory, even a discussion of social norms, and so much more. So I am so excited to kind of jump into this first episode of the New Year series, perhaps the first episode of 2023. It's going to be an amazing year. And what a great way to kick it off with a discussion about New Year's resolutions. So let's get into it and learn all that there is to know about New Year's resolutions. And hopefully learn how we can apply some of the theory, some of the psychology to our own goals so that we can be successful at the end of the day. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
有如此多有趣的概念，比如罗马哲学、自我效能感和自我提升理论，甚至还有对社会规范的讨论，以及更多内容。所以我非常兴奋能投入到这个新年系列的第一期节目中，也许是2023年的第一期节目。这将是令人惊叹的一年。以讨论新年决心来拉开它的序幕，这是多么棒的方式啊。让我们切入正题，了解关于新年决心的一切知识。希望能够了解我们如何将部分理论和心理学应用到我们自己的目标中，以便最终取得成功。2%。这是在有扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中展现出的坚韧意志、体能以及抗压能力的科学原理。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，透过那些主导健康产业的不切实际且极其复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题都是压力导致的。
of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
经历一番艰难困苦，你终将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO PERCENT，可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击金小妹的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟金小妹有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table. right now.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，畅谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field. and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
而我们仍在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上活着做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different. intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我科尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《知难而进》中就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. She's in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones.
搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。2023年，前“钻石单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了前后矛盾之处。她的故事。这开启了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
这是《爱的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这还没完。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱的陷阱》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So, of course, as we always do at the beginning of each episode, we want to break down some of the history behind New Year's resolutions
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。所以，当然，就像我们在每集节目开头所做的那样，我们想剖析一些新年决心的历史背景，
and get our basics down pat before jumping into the psychology and the explanations behind why this concept, this idea of making promises to ourselves at the beginning of the new year, why it even exists. So the origin of making New Year's resolutions, it rests with the Babylonians. For those of you who do not know who these people are, I didn't know who they were, but they were an ancient group of people who lived in present day Iraq from, I think like 2000 to 400 BC and many historians trace the beginnings and the existence of New Year's resolutions back to this group. So these people would reportedly make promises to the gods in hopes that they would earn good favour in the coming year.
并在深入探讨心理学以及解释为什么会存在这种概念、这种在新年伊始向自己许下承诺的想法之前，先把基础知识搞懂。所以，新年决心的起源要追溯到巴比伦人。对于你们中不知道这些人是谁的人来说，我以前也不知道他们是谁，但他们是一群生活在现代伊拉克地区的古代人，时间大约在公元前2000年到公元前400年左右，许多历史学家将新年决心的起源和存在追溯到这个群体。据报道，这些人会向神灵许下承诺，希望能赢得神灵的青睐，在来年获得好运。
So for example, they might make a promise that they're going to have the most successful harvest they've ever seen or be a really good partner or a really good husband. or wife. And by succeeding in that, by fulfilling that goal, that ambition, they almost demonstrated to the gods that they were true to their word, that they were had integrity, that they were good people, and as a result, they would receive good favour, good karma from these same gods. Although I don't think that we make our modern day resolutions to the gods per se, the new year is still and obviously a very important and somewhat spiritual time that represents so many things but mostly new beginnings the future or a new chapter in our lives interestingly this is i think a very common meaning it's applied across different cultures
因此，例如，他们可能会许下承诺，要获得有史以来最丰收的庄稼，或者成为一个真正优秀的伴侣，或者一个真正优秀的丈夫或妻子。通过实现这个目标，通过完成这个目标、这个抱负，他们几乎向神灵证明了他们是守信的，他们是有气节的，他们是好人，因此，他们会从这些神灵那里获得好运、好的因果报应。虽然我认为我们现代人并不是向神灵本身许下新年决心的，但新年仍然而且显然是一个非常重要且有点精神层面的时刻，它代表着许多事情，但主要是新的开始、未来或我们生活中的新篇章。有趣的是，我认为这是一种非常普遍的含义，它适用于不同的文化。
the month of january is actually named after the god janus who was the god of new beginnings So we can see that there is this reverence placed on the new year throughout many cultures and throughout many time periods. I think as humans, we really crave the comfort of meaning and tradition. And the new year is able to bring both of these things and offer somewhat of a dedicated time for reflection and contemplation of what we want from this new period of our lives. and you know it often involves a pretty big celebration as well you know fireworks champagne and all of that but more than that i think it provides a dedicated time for looking back feeling grateful nostalgic
一月份实际上是以神“雅努斯”命名的，他是新开始之神。因此我们可以看到，新年在许多文化和许多历史时期都备受尊崇。我认为作为人类，我们真的很渴望意义和传统的慰藉。新年能够带来这两样东西，并为我们提供一段专门的时间，用来反思和沉思我们希望从我们生活的新阶段中得到什么。你知道，这通常也伴随着相当盛大的庆祝活动，你知道的，烟花、香槟等等，但不仅如此，我认为它提供了一段专门的时间来回顾过去、感受感恩、怀旧，
and perhaps also thinking about what it is about our lives that may be missing something where we feel we may be lacking or dissatisfied where we can improve whilst also being hopeful for the future and invest it in the ways that we can better ourselves. We tend to set resolutions at this time of the year because the new year in particular serves as this cyclical marker of time during which we can re-evaluate and take inventory on our lives. And the drive for making resolutions is very much motivated by this punctuation in time which activates our hopes and our expectations. for what we want to achieve going forward.
也许还会思考我们生活中的什么地方可能缺少了什么，我们觉得可能有所欠缺或不满意的地方，我们可以改进的地方，同时也对未来抱有希望，并致力于寻找能够让我们变得更好的方法。我们往往在这个时候设定决心，因为新年特别是作为一个周期的记号，在这期间我们可以重新评估并盘点我们的生活。而下决心的动力很大程度上是由这个时间节点激发出来的，它激活了我们对于未来想要实现的成就的希望和期望。
So this psychologist, her name is Dr. Strongen, she had a really good explanation for this that I thought would be super relevant when we're talking about why it is that the new year really sparks this desire to change up our lives. And she says that the new year, what it does is gives us kind of a sense of renewal. And it causes us to think about areas in our lives
所以这位心理学家，她的名字叫斯特朗根博士（Dr. Strongen），她对此有一个很好的解释，我认为当我们讨论为什么新年真的会点燃我们改变生活的渴望时，这会非常相关。她说，新年所做的是给我们一种更新的感觉。它促使我们思考生活中那些
where we want to improve and this kind of distinct start of a new chapter of a new year, you know, the clock kind of ticks over into a new calendar. It feels like a natural time to make this change. There is really no better time than the beginning of a new year. And I think this is the marvel and also the significance of a new year for making massive changes to our everyday lives and I guess our overall lifestyle. When we think of New Year's resolutions, I think a few typical categories or examples often come to mind.
我们想要改进的领域，而这种标志着新篇章、新一年的开始，你知道，时钟进入了一个新的日历年，感觉像是做出这种改变的自然时机。真的没有比新年伊始更好的时机了。我认为这就是新年对于彻底改变我们的日常生活和整体生活方式的奇妙之处，也是它的意义所在。当我们想到新年决心时，我想通常会浮现出一些典型的类别或例子。
And there's actually been research on this, on these very categories, these common categories that we see. So this woman, Caitlin Woolie from Cornell, she did some research into New Year's resolutions and she wanted to find out what were the most common types of resolutions. I don't think this is a surprise to anyone. But the majority overwhelmingly, I think it was as high as like 55, 56% of resolutions were health-related. So wanting to exercise more, eat healthy, lose weight, those were by far the most common New Year's resolutions reported. Then we have work-related and financial-related kind of resolutions at about 35%. So a lot of people reported that they are going into the new year. year wanting to save money, get out of debt, get organized by a house, these kind of financial
事实上，对此也有过研究，针对我们看到的这些常见类别。康奈尔大学的凯特琳·伍利（Caitlin Woolie）做了一些关于新年决心的研究，她想找出最常见的新年决心类型是什么。我想这并不让人意外。但绝大多数，我想高达55%、56%的决心都与健康有关。比如想要多锻炼、健康饮食、减肥，这些是迄今为止报告最多的新年决心。然后我们有工作相关和财务相关的决心，大约占35%。所以很多人报告说他们进入新的一年时
and work-related ambitions that they have. And then we also have these social goals. These accounted for about 5 to 10% overall. You know, goals like spending more time with family, making more friends, making time for romance, going on dates, meeting a partner. These were also a pretty big category of New Year's resolutions. I don't think I was surprised at all to hear how many resolutions or goals we make at the start of a new year have to do with our physical health and our physical appearance, mainly just because I think it is a huge source of just general insecurity for many of us, for many, many people. And these goals can be super varied, but they're often focused on things like feeling better in our bodies, maybe being able to accomplish a situation. certain physical feet like a half marathon. Sometimes they have a lot to do with our eating and our diet, but of course also on how we look.
想要省钱、摆脱债务、整理好财务买房，这些是他们拥有的财务和工作相关的抱负。然后我们还有这些社交目标。这些大约占总数的5到10%。你知道，比如花更多时间陪家人、交更多朋友、为浪漫留出时间、约会、结识伴侣这样的目标。这些也是新年决心中相当大的一个类别。听到在新年伊始许下的如此多决心或目标都与我们的身体健康和外表有关，我一点也不感到惊讶，主要是因为我认为这确实是我们许多人、非常多的人普遍感到不安全感的巨大来源。这些目标可以非常多样化，但它们通常集中在诸如在身体中感觉更好之类的事情上，也许能够完成某种身体上的壮举，比如半程马拉松。有时它们与我们的饮食有很大关系，但当然也关乎我们的外表。
Fitness is obviously a part of this, but I definitely have a bit of a bone to pick with goals that are focused on weight loss, just because I actually think they're really hard to achieve, especially with the pressure and the hype of a new year. We get so excited about this. We imagine how we're going to look, you know, what it's going to feel like we don't understand the investment that it sometimes takes. And I've been seeing New Year's resolutions about weight loss everywhere, all over my TikTok right now. And it's kind of what inspired me to do this episode because I began thinking about my own New Year's expectations or goals for
健身显然是其中的一部分，但我对那些专注于减肥的目标绝对有点意见，因为我真的认为它们很难实现，尤其是伴随着新年的压力和炒作。我们对此感到非常兴奋。我们想象自己会是什么样子，你知道，那种感觉会是什么样，我们并不明白这有时需要投入多少精力和时间。我到处都能看到关于减肥的新年决心，现在我的 TikTok 上到处都是。这有点启发了我制作这一集节目，因为我开始思考自己对23年的新年期望或目标，
23 and I can honestly say I think this is the first year that my New Year's resolutions are not focused on what I look like or you know my body which is like so shocking to me I think that they have been focused on that for as long as I can remember there's no shame if that is your new year's resolution you know it's your body it's your choice as long as you're going into it with a healthy and sustainable mindset, go for it. It's honestly your life. And if that's going to make you happier, that's fantastic that you have, you know, decided to focus on that for your health and as an element of your health for 2023. But I think there are other health goals as well that are perhaps more achievable and I would say more holistic. You know, maybe your New Year's resolution is
我可以诚实地说，我认为这是我的新年决心第一次不聚焦于我的外表或者说我的身体，这对我来说太震惊了。我想只要我能记住，它们就一直聚焦于此。如果那是你的新年决心，也没什么好羞耻的，你知道的，那是你的身体，那是你的选择，只要你带着健康和可持续的心态去面对它，那就去做吧。这真的是你的人生。如果这能让你更快乐，那你决定为你的健康以及2023年健康的一个要素而专注于此，这真是太棒了。但我认为还有其他可能更容易实现、而且我认为更全面的健康目标。你知道，也许你的新年决心是
to stop drinking or to drink less. That's one of mine. Next year, I really, I really, I I honestly do not have the time to be hung over as much as I was last year. And I just kind of want to cut back. So that's one of my news resolutions. Another one I see quite often is to like walk 10,000 steps a day. I think these are like that one in particular, that 10,000 step one is a lot more achievable than setting some obscure weight loss goal. Because it's achievable, it can be integrated into your life and it affects so much more. more than just, you know, the number on a scale. It affects the time we spent outdoors. It affects
戒酒或少喝酒。这也是我的目标之一。明年，我真的、真的、我老实说没有时间像去年那样经常宿醉了。我只是想有所克制。所以这是我的新年决心之一。我经常看到的另一个目标是每天走10,000步。我认为这些——特别是那一个，那一万步的目标——比设定一些晦涩难懂的减肥目标要容易实现得多。因为它是可以实现的，它可以融入你的生活，而且它影响的不仅仅是体重秤上的数字。它影响我们呆在户外的受时间。它影响
how we feel in our body. It affects our cardiovascular health. So I think it's a much more well-rounded goal. Another big category that obviously I'm a huge fan of is the mental health resolutions, the mental health goals. These are mainly focused on our emotional well-being and the things that we can do to shift our mindset and our mental perspective. You know, there are the normal ones, like going to therapy, trying to perhaps prioritize your boundaries and your space, but there are some others that I think are fantastic, like reducing your screen time. Our exposure to social media and to just the internet and screens in general can have such a strange and nuanced effect on our mental health. So I think reducing screen time is such a fantastic goal, if that is your
我们身体的感受。它影响我们的心血管健康。所以我认为这是一个更加全面的目标。另一个大类别显然我是它的超级粉丝，那就是心理健康决心、心理健康目标。这些主要集中在我们的情感健康上，以及我们可以做些什么来改变我们的心态和精神视角。你知道，有常规的那些，比如去尝试治疗，试着优先考虑你的界限和个人空间，但还有一些我认为非常棒，比如减少你的屏幕时间。我们对社交媒体、对互联网和屏幕的接触可能会对我们的心理健康产生如此奇怪而微妙的影响。所以我认为减少屏幕时间是一个非常棒的目标，如果那是你的
priority. Reading more, that's an amazing one. It's highly achievable. And another one I saw was to get at least 20 minutes of sun or outdoors time a day. That is such an amazing New Year's resolution. Honestly, it's so easy to integrate into our lives, especially if you live somewhere like Australia where, you know, the weather is sometimes bad, but in general, most of the time, bearable. And it also allows us to incorporate many of the health benefits of being in nature. So I think that if that is something you want to focus on, what an amazing goal. A couple others, just to briefly mention, we talked about financial goals, you know, saving for a particular reason. Maybe you want to buy a house or go on a big trip.
首要任务的话。多读书，这是一个很棒的目标。它很容易实现。我看到的另一个目标是每天至少有20分钟的阳光或户外时间。这是一个非常棒的新年决心。老实说，它很容易融入我们的生活，特别是如果你住在像澳大利亚这样（天气有时不好，但总体而言大部分时间还算可以忍受）的地方。它还让我们能够结合身处大自然中的诸多健康益处。所以我认为如果那是你想关注的事情，这是一个多么棒的目标。还有几个，简单提一下，我们讨论过财务目标，比如为了某种特定原因存钱。也许你想买房或来一次长途旅行。
And then there are some other, like, niche goals and achievements. like, I don't know, wanting to climb Everest or to knit 50 mini jackets for your cats, start a business, start a podcast. That one sounds pretty familiar. And these kind of goals are often super unique and I would say not shared by many people, which at times, on one hand, I think, can make it harder to form community. But it also makes it so much more worthwhile because fewer people have that goal and achieving it is going to be so much more sweet and such an amazing feeling. Obviously, this is not an exhaustive list. I honestly think that any facet of our lives where we're perhaps not quite satisfied or fulfilled or would like to do better can be made into a goal.
然后还有其他一些小众目标和成就。比如，我不知道，想要征服珠穆朗玛峰，或者为你的猫织50件迷你夹克，创业，办一个播客。听起来那个听起来很耳熟。这类目标通常超级独特，而且我想不会被很多人分享，有时一方面，我认为这可能会使建立社区变得更加困难。但这也让它变得更有价值，因为拥有该目标的 人更少，而实现它的感觉会更加甜蜜，也是一种奇妙的体验。显然，这不是一个详尽的清单。我老实说，我们生活中任何我们可能不太满意、不够充实或想要做得更好的方面都可以变成一个目标。
And sometimes the significance of a new year, of a new leaf, a new chapter, but also this explicit kind of start date and point from which to track our progress can be a huge enabler of our success. But let's now tackle the psychology behind how we can create realistic New Year's resolutions and almost offer a bit of an equation for success so that we can start 2023 with the best versions of ourselves in mind. So we have explained some of the history, the categories, the traditions behind New Year's resolutions, but now to the psychology. What is it about the new year that causes us to have these elaborate and grand expectations
有时新年的意义、翻开新的一页、新的篇章，以及这种明确的开始日期和追踪我们进展的起点，可以成为我们成功的重要助推器。但现在让我们来探讨一下背后的心理学，即我们如何才能制定出现实的新年决心，并几乎为成功提供一个公式，以便我们能够以最好的自己迎接2023年。所以我们已经解释了新年决心背后的一些历史、类别、传统，但现在来到心理学。新年的什么特性让我们对自我抱有如此精细和宏大的期望，去设定这些决心？我认为作为人类，我们天生且本能地非常倾向于自我提升。
for ourselves to set these resolutions? I think as humans, we are naturally and innately very attuned to self-improvement. it is very much part of our complexity and a unique aspect of our species that we have this capacity to consider the future and ourselves within it. And with that, we tend to imagine versions of ourselves that do not yet exist, ones that might be better. Because of this unique ability, we're able to set goals and objectives that lead to better versions of ourselves. That is the premise of New Year's resolutions. The idea, though, of a New Year's resolution, it tends to rest on three fairly important psychological concepts. The first being personal development,
这是我们复杂性的一部分，也是我们物种独特的一个方面，即我们具有考虑未来以及我们在其中的自我的能力。伴随着这一点，我们倾向于想象尚未存在的更好的自我版本。由于这种独特的能力，我们能够设定目标和宗旨，从而引导出更好的自我。这就是新年决心的前提。然而，新年决心的理念往往建立在三个相当重要的心理学概念之上。第一个是个人发展，
the second being self-efficacy, and finally the idea of social norms. Personal development, it's all about looking inward and focusing on the ways to better yourself. It's so obvious how that has a relationship to New Year's resolutions. But essentially this focus allows us to increase our self-awareness, our self-esteem, and to fulfill future aspirations that we may have for our lives. When we make a New Year's resolution, whatever it may be, we are channeling our personal development and our focus on personal growth and kind of, yeah, channeling that in a way that allows us to be productive and to live a more fulfilled and satisfying life. Without this ability or the skills to reflect inwards and upwards, we can remain fairly stagnant and unsatisfied with our
第二个是自我效能感，最后是社会规范的概念。个人发展，它完全关乎向内看，专注于如何让自己变得更好。这显而易见与新年决心有何关联。但本质上，这种关注使我们能够提高自我意识、自尊，并实现我们对生活的未来抱负。当我们许下新年决心时，无论它是什么，我们都在引导我们的个人发展和对个人成长的关注，并且以一种能够让我们富有成效、过上更充实和满意生活的方式来引导它。如果没有这种能力或向内和向上反思的技巧，我们可能会在生活中停滞不前、感到不满意，这就是为什么新年是向自己许下某些承诺的重要时刻，因为它们专注于改善我们的生活以提升整体质量。所以，即使我们没有完全实现我们的目标，我认为仅仅是反思我们想要改进的地方、我们想要去的地方、为之投入精力的这种行为本身就是非常有价值的。
lives, which is why the new year is such an important time to make certain promises to ourselves, because they are focused on improving our lives in order to enhance the overall quality. So even if we don't fully realize our goals, the very act I think of just reflecting on where we want to improve, where we want to be, putting energy towards that is so valuable. Because not only does it mean that we have a sense of the future and a sense of meaning, but we also have a desire to be better, which is in itself a very inherently valuable idea to have. The second psychological concept that I think is perhaps even more important to consider in the context of New Year's resolutions is self-efficacy. So self-efficacy is at the very core, perhaps the central pillar to establishing goals for ourselves
因为这不仅意味着我们对未来有感知、对意义有感知，而且我们也有变得更好的愿望，这本身就是一个具有内在价值的想法。我认为在新年决心的背景下，甚至更需要考虑的第二个心理学概念是自我效能感。所以自我效能感是核心，也许是为我们在新年设定目标的中心支柱。本质上，它指的是我们对自己有能力执行产生特定结果所需行为的信念。所以只要稍微分解一下。
in the new year. Essentially, it refers to our belief in our capacity to execute the behavior is necessary to produce specific outcomes. So just to break that down a little bit, more. It essentially encompasses our confidence that our behavior and our actions will be able to exert an influence over our environment and over our future so that we can achieve our goals. Without self-efficacy, without this belief in our ability to alter our lives, the idea of a New Year's resolution, it literally wouldn't exist. It wouldn't be anything. but wishful thinking. That is what distinguishes the New Year's resolution from just, you know, a fantasy. It's that acknowledgement that what we want for our lives will require our effort.
它本质上包含了我们的信心，即我们的行为和行动将能够对我们的环境和未来施加影响，以便我们能够实现目标。如果没有自我效能感，没有对我们改变生活能力的这种信念，新年决心的概念就根本不会存在。它将什么都不是，只是美丽的愿望。这就是新年决心与单纯的幻想的区别。它是对我们对生活的诉求将需要我们付出努力的认可。
And therefore, this belief that our actions, our behaviours will actually have some influence over whether or not we achieve a certain goal. You know, without self-efficacy, why would we even try? There's no point trying. I think virtually all people can identify some form of goal that they have. However, I think where we go wrong is that most of us don't always think about the fact that putting these plans into action isn't as simple as we think. And self-efficacy is going to play a major role and how we approach this goal and how we approach this challenge. You know, people with stronger self-efficacy, they often recover really quickly from setbacks. They make a plan.
因此，这种信念认为我们的行动、我们的行为实际上会对我们是否实现某个目标产生一些影响。你知道，如果没有自我效能感，我们为什么还要去尝试？尝试毫无意义。我认为实际上所有人都能确定某种他们拥有的目标。然而，我认为我们犯错的地方在于，我们大多数人并不总是考虑到将这些计划付诸行动并不像我们想象的那么简单。自我效能感将在我们如何对待这个目标以及我们如何应对这个挑战方面发挥重要作用。你知道，自我效能感更强的人，他们经常能从挫折中迅速恢复。他们制定计划。
They view problems as something to be mastered. And they really are a lot more invested in their goals. And they're invested in the activities that they are required to do to achieve these goals. In contrast, we see people who have lower or weaker self-efficacy tend to really avoid some of the challenging tasks and behaviors that are required. they focus a lot on the potential of failure and on the negative outcomes and they quickly lose confidence in their personal abilities right like they don't feel confident that they have the agency they have the strength they have the skills necessary to achieve their goal
他们将问题视为需要掌握的东西。他们对自己的目标投入更多。而且他们投入于实现这些目标所需的活动中。相比之下，我们看到自我效能感较低或较弱的人往往倾向于回避一些具有挑战性的任务和行为。他们把大量精力放在潜在的失败和消极结果上，并迅速失去对自己个人能力的信心，对吧？就像他们不觉得自信自己拥有代理权、拥有力量、拥有实现目标所需的技能一样。
obviously if you have set an ambitious new year's resolution whatever it may be a strong sense of self-efficacy is going to be a great asset to achieving this goal. And importantly, self-efficacy, it's not something you're born with, right? It's actually something that you can develop and train within yourself. And there are a few ways to do that. Firstly, by celebrating your successes, by really consciously recognizing instances in which you have been able to influence your destiny or change outcome, modeling and observing the behaviours and stories of others, having those positive role models or mentors to kind of show you that this is possible. And another way is to seek out positive feedback and positive affirmations. Obviously, when you hear positive feedback from others,
显然，如果你设定了一个雄心勃勃的新年决心，无论它是什么，强烈的自我效能感将是实现这个目标的巨大资产。重要的是，自我效能感不是生来就有的，对吧？它实际上是你可以培养和训练自己的东西。有几种方法可以做到这一点。首先，通过庆祝你的成功，通过真正有意识地认出你能够影响你的命运或改变结果的实例，模拟和观察他人的行为和故事，拥有那些积极的榜样或导师来向你展示这是可能的。另一种方法是寻求积极的反馈和积极的肯定。显然，当你听到来自他人的积极反馈时，
that can really help improve your sense of self-efficacy and not only that, but your sense that you are actually achieving your goal, that it is recognizable from the perspective of other people. You know, if your therapist tells you that you're doing a really good job at prioritizing your mental health, that's setting boundaries, that's going to be so encouraging and it's going to make you want to keep going. But in contrast, and on the other hand, negative feedback, negative comments can also have a pretty powerful undermining effect. So be conscious about who you share your goals and ambitions with. I don't think there is anything more demoralizing than someone telling you that what you're doing is not worth it or that you're going to fail. It's such a terrible, terrible feeling. So if you
这确实有助于提高你的自我效能感，不仅如此，还会增强你实际上正在实现你的目标的信念，这从其他人的角度来看是可以识别的。你知道，如果你的心理学家告诉你，你在优先考虑心理健康方面做得很好，你在划定界限，那将是非常鼓舞人心的，它会让你想继续下去。但相比之下，另一方面，消极的反馈、消极的评论也会产生相当强大的破坏作用。所以要注意你和谁分享你的目标和抱负。我认为没有什么比别人告诉你你所做的不值得或你将要失败更令人沮丧的了。这是一种糟糕透顶的感觉。所以如果你
want to succeed, you have to create a supportive environment that contains people who really believe in your abilities and they believe in your success. Finally, making a New Year's resolution, it's somewhat of a social norm these days, right? Like a social norm being these kind of informal rules or expectations that we have, it's very much influenced by what we see other people doing. It gets to December, early January and people start talking about their New Year's resolutions and we feel like we should probably have a few of our own. This is not a bad thing at all. In fact, I think it's one of the more positive social norms
想要成功，你必须创造一个支持性的环境，里面包含那些真正相信你的能力并且相信你能成功的人。最后，许下新年决心，这在这些日子里有点像是一种社会规范，对吧？社会规范就是我们拥有的这种非正式规则或期望，它很大程度上受到我们看到其他人所做的事情的影响。到了12月、1月上旬，人们开始谈论他们的新年决心，我们觉得我们也应该有几个自己的决心。这绝不是一件坏事。事实上，我认为这是我们节目中讨论过的更积极的社会规范之一，
that we've discussed on the show, because as we said, the primary reason for setting this kind of goal at the start of the year is for self-growth. So as long as we're not harming anyone, they seem to be overall a pretty positive thing. Well, at least that's what we think is the case. but it might actually be that New Year's resolutions are neither positive or negative,
因为正如我们所说，在年初设定这种类型目标的主要原因是自我成长。所以只要我们不伤害任何人，它们总体上似乎是一件相当积极的事情。好吧，至少我们认为是这样的。但实际上情况可能是，新年决心既不是积极的也不是消极的，
especially when we consider how many of us and how many of our resolutions end up failing. And that is what I want to discuss next. Why is it that so many of our ambitions for the new year end up being forgotten by the second or third week of January? Every year in early January, millions and millions of us resolve to change something about our lives, change something about our behavior, whether it is to get really fit, to eat better, to save money, spend more time with our friends, whatever it is. There is no denying that most of us have something in mind that we want to change in 2023.
尤其是当我们考虑到我们有多少人以及我们的多少决心最终以失败告终时。而这正是我接下来要讨论的。为什么我们对新年的许多抱负最终在1月第二或第三周就被遗忘了？每年的1月上旬，我们数以百万计的人下定决心要改变我们生活中的某些东西，改变我们行为中的某些东西，无论是变得非常健康、吃得更好、省钱、花更多时间陪朋友，无论是什么。无可否认，我们大多数人在2023年都有一些想要改变的事情。
Here is the sad reality though. For most of us, these New Year's resolutions are going to fall by the wayside within a few weeks. The best example I think of this, of the early failure of many resolutions, is thinking about how busy your gym is in the first weeks of January, yet by, you know, February, they're normally back to usual. That's because we often get wrapped up in the excitement of setting the resolution. of imagining the outcome without realizing how much commitment it can take. The easiest step to making a new is resolution is telling yourself that you're going to do it, is making that promise and imagining the success, imagining your future body or your future financial situation or your amazing life, especially in that moment before we actually have to do some of the work.
然而，这里有一个悲惨的现实。对于我们大多数人来说，这些新年决心将在几周内付诸东流。我想这最好的例子就是1月的前几周你的健身房有多忙，然而到了2月份，它们通常又恢复正常了。这是因为我们经常沉浸在设定决心的兴奋中。沉浸在想象结果中，而没有意识到这需要付出多少承诺。制定新决心的最简单一步是告诉自己你要去做，是许下承诺并想象成功，想象你未来的身材或未来的财务状况或你精彩的生活，特别是在我们实际不得不做一些工作之前的那个时刻。
it is very easy to fantasize, but for anyone who's actually set a new year's resolution, it's a lot harder to actually achieve that goal because it requires often a lot of tedious and persistent work. I don't really think it's even a goal, right, if it's easy to achieve. That's part of the allure of New Year's resolutions is that they are really large and grand and significant, and they require that significance of. the new year in order to begin. There are quite a few reasons I want to discuss as to why it's so difficult to stick to our new year's resolutions and many of these explanations have some pretty fascinating psychology attached. Firstly, a large amount of our daily behaviours tend to be
幻想非常容易，但对任何真正许过新年愿望的人来说，要真正实现这个目标要困难得多，因为它通常需要大量枯燥且持久的工作。老实说，如果很容易实现，我甚至不认为那算是一个目标。新年愿望的魅力之一就在于它们非常宏大、重要，而且它们需要新年的那种重要意义作为开始。我想讨论很多原因，解释为什么坚持新年愿望如此困难，其中许多解释都有着非常迷人的心理学背景。首先，我们大量的日常行为往往是由
motivated by what we see as unconscious and automatic habits that haven't made. many ways been ingrained in us since our childhood, since our teenage years. We unconsciously reach for the same types of food, we wake up at the same time, we see the same people, we use the same forms of transport, because these actions and these behaviours have become so habitual, and it makes it really difficult to change. And over time, these repetitive ways of behaving tend to become very much automatically cued by the situations that we're in. And they're completely independent from our deliberate thought processes. So much of what we do on a day-to-day basis, we do without thinking.
我们认为的那些无意识且自动化的习惯所驱动，这些习惯在很多方面从我们的童年、少年时期就已经根深蒂固。我们无意识地去拿同类型的食物，在同一时间醒来，见到同样的人，使用相同的交通工具，因为这些行动和行为已经变得如此习惯成真，这使得改变变得非常困难。随着时间的推移，这些重复的行为方式往往会完全被我们所处的情境自动触发。它们完全独立于我们刻意的思维过程。我们在日常生活中所做的很多事情，都是在不经意间完成的。
When we set a New Year's resolution, though, that is a very deliberate, a very conscious action, a very conscious thought. And it can be really difficult to integrate. this conscious and deliberate thing we want to achieve into our daily lives and into our daily lives that are filled with automatic behaviours and unconscious habits. Because they are so hard to integrate and because a lot of our resolutions often require almost rewriting or rewiring our automatic behaviours, it takes a lot of conscious energy to uphold these resolutions, which is why they often fail.
然而，当我们许下新年愿望时，那是一个非常刻意、非常有意识的行动，是一个非常刻意的想法。要把这个我们想要实现的有意识、刻意的事情融入我们的日常生活，融入那些充满自动行为和无意识习惯的日常生活中，可能会非常困难。正因为它们极难融入，且我们的许多愿望往往几乎需要重写或重新连接我们的自动行为，所以维持这些愿望需要消耗大量的有意识精力，这就是它们经常失败的原因。
This explains why achieving our New Year's resolutions it's not just about pure determination. It's not just about how much you want it. The act of achieving any goal requires a lot of intense, concentrated energy. And more than that, it requires rewriting unconscious behaviors you've probably followed for years and years and years. Often we don't really map out or think about what it's going to take to accomplish a goal. And instead we rely very much so on that excitement of the new year as the thing that's going to push us to accomplish this goal, this buzz, this excitement, this expectation. And then that buzz wears off. Or maybe you realize that actually you set a few unrealistic expectations for yourself. For example, you know, if you've decided that 2023, you're going to run a marriage. and you've bought tickets for a race in April, it's highly unlikely that you're going to do that. You really set yourself up to fail because you haven't been honest or realistic with yourself.
这解释了为什么实现新年愿望不仅仅取决于纯粹的决心。这不仅关乎你有多渴望它。实现任何目标都需要大量强烈的、集中的精力。不仅如此，它还需要重写你可能已经遵循了多年甚至数十年的无意识行为。通常，我们并没有真正规划或思考实现一个目标需要付出什么。相反，我们极大地依赖新年带来的兴奋感，将其作为推动我们实现目标的动力——这种兴奋、这种狂热、这种期待。然后，这种狂热感就会消退。或者你可能会意识到，其实你为自己设定了一些不切实际的期望。比如，如果你决定在2023年去跑马拉松，
The cycle of making and subsequently breaking resolutions, it boils down to one core issue or concept, and that is honesty. being honest with yourself about what it is you want, why you want to achieve it and how achievable it is. So before you set your resolution for 2023, it's really important to ask yourself some of those core questions and be honest with yourself in answering them. Why is it that this goal is important to you? And how do you imagine it's going to make your life better? really, really think about that. Is the outcome of your resolution? Is it going to be enough to motivate you to do the things that you need to do?
而你已经买好了四月份比赛的门票，你几乎不可能做到这一点。你其实是在给自己设置失败的陷阱，因为你对自己不够诚实或不够现实。许下愿望随后又打破愿望的循环，归根结底是一个核心问题或概念，那就是诚实。对自己诚实，弄清楚你想要什么、你为什么要实现它以及它的可实现性有多高。所以在你为2023年设定愿望之前，非常重要的一点是问自己一些核心问题，并在回答时对自己诚实。为什么这个目标对你如此重要？你想象它会怎样让你的生活变得更好？认认真真、仔仔细细地去思考这个问题。你的愿望带来的结果，
And is that final end goal, something that is achievable? Honestly, it's also important to reflect on the times when you've tried in the past to achieve this thing or to pursue this change and what went wrong. You know, maybe last year you wanted to wake up at 7 a.m. every day, but you didn't think about the fact that you work a nine to five or that a lot of your socialising happens in the evening. So think about why you failed. Think about what it was about your environment, about your surroundings that made it difficult to accomplish this goal. We often, you know, set lofty goals for the future without seriously and honestly assessing why we've probably
足以激励你去做好你需要做的事情吗？而且这个最后的终极目标是能够实现的吗？老实说，回顾你过去曾尝试实现这件事或追求这种改变却遭遇失败的经历，这也同样重要。你知道，也许去年你想要每天早上7点起床，但你没有考虑到你做的是朝九晚五的工作，或者你的很多社交活动都发生在晚上。所以，思考一下你为什么失败了。思考一下你的环境、你的周围究竟是哪里让你难以实现这个目标。我们经常为未来设定崇高的目标，却不去严肃且诚实地评估我们过去为什么
struggled in the past and without examining where we are resistant to change that cycle of that cycle of excitement and resolve and then failure continues to repeat. It's also really important to be honest about what else is going to have to change in your life to meet your goal and to meet your resolution. We often think about our New Year's resolutions as a pretty isolated desire or an isolated dream without recognizing the lifestyle change that they are going to require. The one I always think of is the New Year's resolution to quit drinking, and that's one of mine for this year.
一直在挣扎，也不去审视我们对改变的抗拒在哪里，兴奋、决心随之又是失败的循环便不断重复。同样非常重要的一点是，要诚实地面对为了实现你的目标和愿望，你的生活中还必须发生什么其他的改变。我们经常把新年愿望当作一种相当孤立的渴望或孤立的梦想，却没有认识到它们将带来的生活方式的转变。我脑海里总是浮现的一个例子就是戒酒的新年愿望，这也是我今年的愿望之一。
Quitting, you know, to quit drinking, quitting alcohol, it sounds simple enough, right? You know, you just say no. You just don't drink. And when you think about it on an individual basis, when you're home by yourself, it sounds pretty achievable, right? Like, it sounds fairly simple. But then you have to think about it in terms of the. other contexts in our lives, in which alcohol is present, and how much it tends to dominate
戒酒听起来很简单，对吧？你知道，你只要说不就行了。就是不喝酒。当你独自在家时，从个人的角度去考虑，这听起来相当可行，对吧？听起来挺简单。但随后你必须结合我们生活中其他充斥着酒精的情境去思考，以及酒精往往如何在多大程度上主导了
social occasions and celebrations. Are you going to be okay with not drinking during these times, or maybe missing out, because of this choice? And are you going to be able to make the changes to your overall lifestyle to enact this goal? By asking ourselves these questions, and also answering them honestly, we're actually setting ourselves up for success because we can alter our resolutions and be more realistic from the get-go and therefore more likely to succeed. There are, of course, some other reasons why we typically fail our new-year resolutions just to, you know, list off a couple. Sometimes we just lack accountability. You know, it's very easy to fail if the only person you're going to disappoint is yourself. Sometimes our goal doesn't allow for small wins,
社交场合和庆祝活动。在这些时刻你不喝酒，或者因为这个选择而错过了什么，你觉得可以接受吗？你能够改变你的整体生活方式来实现这个目标吗？通过问自己这些问题，并且诚实地回答它们，我们其实是在为成功做准备，因为我们可以从一开始就调整我们的愿望，使其更加现实，从而更有可能成功。当然，我们通常会未能实现新年愿望还有其他一些原因，随口列举几个。有时候我们只是缺乏问责机制。如果你唯一会让她失望的人只有你自己，失败是非常容易的。有时我们的目标不允许有微小的胜利，
so we give up because we don't see any progress. Maybe it is a lack of planning, or the stakes are just too low, and sometimes it's just about self-doubt and not believing that we're able to do them. We're not able to achieve what we set our minds to. With all of that in mind, I really want to turn to our final point for this episode, and perhaps the most significant. How can we actually be successful with all of this information and knowledge in mind? What can we learn from our failures so that we can see through our resolutions? We can make the change that we want to in our lives. Luckily for us, there is quite a lot of research on this. So I've gathered a few tips for us to all share and to hopefully learn from. Firstly,
所以我们放弃了，因为我们看不到任何进展。也许是缺乏计划，或者是赌注太低，有时只是因为自我怀疑，不相信我们有能力做到。我们觉得自己无法实现内心的想法。带着所有这些思考，我真的很想谈谈我们这一集的最后一个要点，也许也是最重要的一点。带着所有这些信息和知识，我们究竟该如何取得成功？我们能从失败中学到什么，以便能够真正实现我们的愿望？我们可以做出我们想要的改变。幸运的是，关于这一点有相当多的研究。所以我收集了一些建议，供大家分享，并希望从中吸取教训。首先，
Start small. Creating smaller goals that are practical and don't restrict you too much is going to be so much more achievable because those goals and the actions required to meet them are not going to disrupt your life as much. Think about all of those automatic behaviours that we were talking about before. Undermining them and rewriting them takes a lot of effort. But if we start out small, you know, maybe by initially trying to exercise just for five minutes out of the day or just trying to replace certain foods that are making us feel unwell. It's a lot easier to integrate into our lives rather than trying to completely shift our lifestyle overnight. These resolutions are also be easier for you to stick to because you're not going to feel like you're missing out
从小处着手。设定更小、更切实可行且不会对你限制太多的目标，会更容易实现，因为这些目标以及实现它们所需的行动不会对你的生活造成太大干扰。想想我们之前谈过的所有那些自动行为。破坏它们并重写它们需要付出很大的努力。但如果我们从小处着手，比如最初试着一天只锻炼五分钟，或者只是试着替换掉那些让我们感觉不舒服的食物。这比试图在一夜之间彻底改变生活方式更容易融入我们的生活。这些愿望也会更容易让你坚持下去，因为你不会觉得自己错过了什么，
and you'll still be able to move closer to your big goal. Sometimes I think we get so excited and we are so impatient that we just rush to the finish line. And what ends up happening is that it's A, not very sustainable, and B, we just end up failing because any kind of massive life change is going to take so much energy. Similar to this is ensuring that your goals are clearly defined. I think often we set these very big sweeping goals and we make these big statements like, I want to be healthier or I want to make. new friends or I want to be more successful. But unfortunately, those goals as amazing as they sound,
并且你仍然能够朝着你的宏大目标迈进。有时我认为我们太兴奋、太急躁，以至于我们只是冲向终点线。结果就是：A，这不是很可持续；B，我们最终还是会失败，因为任何巨大的生活与改变都需要消耗大量的精力。与此类似的是确保你的目标有清晰的定义。我认为我们经常设定这些非常宏大、笼统的目标，并做出诸如“我想变得更健康”或“我想结交新朋友”或“我想变得更成功”这样的大胆声明。但不幸的是，这些目标听起来再怎么美妙，
they're not very clear and it's hard to hold yourself accountable if you don't really have a vision or an idea of success in mind. So making sure that you know exactly what it is you're working for, you create a resolution so that you can actionably see when you're getting closer to the end outcome is going to really help you. In a similar vein to both of those things, I think also limiting yourself to a few resolutions, maybe just one, is also going to be really, really helpful and really enable your success. It's really tempting to do these big to-do lists and to have all these really insane expectations for what we're capable of doing.
它们并不是非常清晰，如果你心里没有对成功的愿景或概念，就很难让自己承担责任。因此，确保你确切知道自己在为什么努力，制定一个愿望，以便你能切实地看到自己何时正在接近最终结果，这真的会很有帮助。与这两点类似，我认为把愿望限制在少数几个，也许仅仅一个，也会非常非常有帮助，并且能够真正促成你的成功。列出庞大的待办事项清单，对自己的能力抱有所有这些疯狂的期望，真的非常诱人。
Maybe you're someone who can handle that amount of pressure and that many things on your mind. But most of us can't really focus on a huge list at once. It's better to break it down into maybe just one or two, one or two goals that we really want to achieve. And that way we're not as easily overwhelmed and as frustrated. And we can integrate those goals into our life a bit better. If we've decided, you know, I want to exercise more and then I want to eat better
也许你是那种能够应对那种压力、脑海中能装下那么多事情的人。但我们大多数人确实无法同时关注一张巨大的清单。最好把它分解为可能仅仅一两个、我们真正想要实现的一两个目标。这样一来，我们就不会那么容易感到压抑和沮丧。我们可以更好地将这些目标融入我们的生活。如果我们已经决定，“我想多锻炼，然后我想吃得更好，
and then I want to be more sustainable and I want to spend money better, that is a lot. That is a lot. So maybe try and find a goal that links all of them, like walking to work. That is sustainable. It's great exercise and it saves you money because you don't have to pay for petrol or pay for transport.
然后我想更环保，我想更好地花钱”，那可就太多了。那真的是太多了。所以也许可以尝试找到一个能将所有这些联系起来的目标，比如步行上班。这很环保。这是很好的锻炼，而且能为你省钱，因为你不必支付汽油费或交通费。
Another few tips that I kind of gathered was to be realistic. I think we've talked about that already. Find community and with that accountability. If your goal is shared, you're able to relate to others who are going through similar things or facing similar setbacks and also you feel accountable and you're excited to pursue the goal because you have community surrounding it. Find a way to track your progress and see the small wins. When we set a big goal and it's going to take a lot for us to get there, we can become disheartened quite easily
我收集的另外几个建议是要现实一点。我想我们已经讨论过这一点了。寻找社群，并伴随着问责制。如果你的目标是共享的，你就能与那些经历相似事情或面临类似挫折的人产生共鸣，而且你也会感到有责任感，并因为周围有社群的支持而对追求目标感到兴奋。找到一种追踪进度并看到微小胜利的方法。当我们设定了一个大目标，并且需要付出很多努力才能到达那里时，我们很容易会感到灰心，
because we don't see any output from our efforts. So find a way to track your progress or to give yourself some small wins to motivate you along the way. One way that I do this is I create kind of like a visual vision board or a resource to think about what I want to achieve and why. And it helps me keep focused and really visualize the outcome that I want and why I want it. It's been so helpful. I do this at the start of most years where I create like a bit of a collage about where I see my year going. It's firstly a really great way to reflect and see what it is that I've realized about that. But it also makes it really clear to me about what it is I'm working towards and I don't lose sight in all the chaos of our day-to-day lives.
因为我们看不到努力的产出。所以要找到一种追踪进度或给自己一些小胜利的方法，以便在这一路上激励自己。我做到这一点的一种方法是创建一种视觉愿景板或资源，来思考我想实现什么以及为什么。它有助于我保持专注，并真正将我想要的结果以及我为什么想要它可视化。这真的太有帮助了。我在大多数年份的开始都会这样做，制作一个关于我看到自己这一年走向的拼贴画。这首先是一个反思并看看我对此意识到什么的绝佳方式，但它也让我非常清楚地知道我在为什么努力，在日常生活的种种混乱中我不会迷失方向。
Finally, it's so important to be mindful. take responsibility for your actions and to stay committed, but also not get too wrapped up in one goal, right? You want your life to be enjoyable. And often if you put all your eggs in one basket, if you're too dedicated, if you go about it really intensely, you're not going to be successful because you're just going to be exhausted and you're going to lose motivation really, really fast. So start with a picture of your future self in mind, make that image big and bright. imagine what it feels like, imagine how you feel, and hold that really deeply.
最后，保持正念非常重要。对你的行为负责并保持专注，但也不要太过于纠结于一个目标，对吧？你希望你的生活充满乐趣。通常，如果你把所有的鸡蛋放在一个篮子里，如果你过于投入，如果你以非常强烈的方式去做，你都不会成功，因为你只会筋疲力尽，而且你会非常非常快地失去动力。所以，带着对未来自己的憧憬开始吧，把那个形象画得宏大而明亮。想象那种感觉，想象你的感受，并深深地坚守它。
Hold on to it as a daily reminder for what you are working for and why you're working towards that. Change your phone background or something about your environment that reminds you of your goal every day. I saw this really interesting quote. I think it's a great thing to share to end up, to, you know, to wrap up this episode. Winners and losers have the same goals. It's all about who is most consistent. You're allowed to have setbacks, you're allowed to have failures, but if you keep working at it day by day, you just aim to be 1% better every day.
把它当作每天的提醒，提醒你在为之努力什么，以及你为什么要朝着那个方向努力。更换你的手机壁纸或改变你环境中能每天提醒你目标的东西。我看到过一句非常有趣的名言。我认为这是一个分享以结束、以（你知道的）总结这一集的好东西。赢家和输家拥有相同的目标。关键全在于谁最具连贯性。你可以经历挫折，你可以经历失败，但如果你日复一日地继续努力，你只是旨在每天进步1%。
It's going to be achievable. And I wish you the best of luck. I hope that you're successful. How amazing to be setting New Year's resolutions. I am so excited for the new year and all that's going to come with it. It's going to be a big year for the podcast, and I cannot thank you enough for supporting me throughout 2022. So thank you to all the new listeners, to everyone who shared, to everyone who's
这是可以实现的。我祝你一切顺利。我希望你能成功。新年许愿是多么美妙的事情。我为新年以及随之而来的一切感到无比兴奋。对于播客来说这将是意义重大的一年，对于你们在2022年对我的支持，我感激不尽。所以感谢所有新听众，感谢所有分享的人，感谢所有
messaged me and followed me. I am so grateful and I cannot wait to push this even further and do so many amazing things in the new year. If you enjoyed this episode, if you think that other people would enjoy it as well, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you get your podcasts. It really helps the show to grow and to reach people so if you feel called to do so it makes a huge difference and yeah i would love i'd be very grateful if you would do that and if you're interested in seeing more of my content please follow our instagram at that psychology podcast often i let listeners of the show decide the episodes that i publish for the week so if that is something you are interested in please give us a follow and participate
给我发消息并关注我的人。我非常感激，我迫不及待地想把这个做得更好，并在新年来临之际做更多了不起的事情。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你认为其他人也会喜欢它，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你获取播客的任何地方留下五星好评。这真的有助于节目的成长并接触到更多人，所以如果你有心这么做，那将产生巨大的影响，是的，如果你能这样做我会非常感激。如果你有兴趣看到我的更多内容，请关注我们的Instagram账号that psychology podcast。通常我会让节目的听众来决定我本周发布的剧集，所以如果这是你感兴趣的事情，请给我们一个关注并以这种方式参与
in the community that way thank you again for listening Good luck if you've set a New Year's resolution. I'm sure you're going to do amazing. And I will see you next week for a new episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
到社群中。再次感谢收听。如果你设定了新年愿望，祝你好运。我确信你会做得棒极了。我们下周的新节目再见。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健康和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。在《Look Back at It》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重大时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过它的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一个懂行的有执照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Miancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吧？我对测试动了一次手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼西尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day. the same prolific con artist. They take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要面对后果了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时。她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。听女友的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。